the big question is whether a machine
could be conscious um maybe I'll just
address the issue from my perspective as
the former leader of a big project at
Nasa and the NASA chair
because their my job was to articulate
the relationship between Consciousness
and intelligence and talk about how we
might locate either one in the universe
and one thing I want to caution against
actually and I know all of us here we
have very detailed metaphysical theories
of Consciousness is assuming
from our theories that we can read in
to the search for conscious machines or
conscious beings on other planets
because look at the search for life in
the context of astrobiology
when you look at the definition of life
that NASA endorses for example
self-replicating and capable of
biological evolution
it is tremendously open capable of
darwinian evolution in particular to the
possibility that life could look very
different on other planets it doesn't
need to be
recognizably life to us the big thing
that I think we need to do here when we
search for other forms of Consciousness
is keep an open mind and realize that
it's going to look very different than
the human case and I think the
interesting question here from a
theoretical standpoint is how different
will allow it to be before we say it's
not Consciousness at all which is one
thing I want to throw out there so
Bernardo and I both thought well
Consciousness is essentially the
phenomenal feel well to me that does
seem like a necessary ingredient
in Consciousness and if a machine lacks
it then to me it doesn't
seem conscious it has some other
qualities and maybe based on those
it will be dangerous or it will be of
moral significance but I think that
that is one thing where
if we were to look for Consciousness
elsewhere
we might take as a fundamental
ingredient but I think it will be very
very different
when we get to the case of synthetic
machines briefly you said it was
necessary to felt experience of
Consciousness is it also sufficient
if that's too long of an answer then
we'll get to Dons
Define that felt quality I mean for
example there are some people who define
consciousness in such a demanding way
like Daniel Dennett in his paper quinine
qualia uh you know where he listed like
seven fundamental ingredients or other
people try to build in a whole Theory
like a higher order Theory Of
Consciousness that intellectualizes
consciousness
and that's where I think we need to be
incredibly open and humble and not
import our own theories of consciousness
into the debate too early